I often get asked if I think I'm
ever going to build something useful,
and maybe someday I will.
But the way Isee it,
I already have because I've
built myself this job.
It's somethingthat I could
never have planned for,
Instead it happened just because I was
enthusiastic about what I was doing,
and I was sharing that
enthusiasm with otherpeople.
To me that's the true
beauty of making useless things,
because it's this acknowledgmentthat you
don't always know what the best answer is.
And it turns off that voice in your head
thattells you that you know
exactly how the world works.
And maybe a toothbrush
helmet isn't theanswer,
but at least you're asking the question.